so give us just a little bit of idea how
you got started writing screenplays
well um i was i was very very lucky i
i was working at rolling stone
and uh and and i had read a couple books
and one of the books
charlie simpson's apocalypse was
nominated for the national book
and and an executive in uae named march
ambassador
ran the four nominees
charlie simpson and she said i think you
write
very cinematic and the and can you come
down and meet with us
so i went down and she said you know
would you like to do
something and because you you're so
cinematic is there anything you want to
do
you know it was very cool i said you
know i i
i've never thought about doing
screenplays but
i always wanted to write the great
american up right and then the uh
but i'll go back and i'll think about it
now i was making no money at rolling
stone and
i was going through our pockets each
night to see how we're going to support
ourselves
and i thought about it for a while and i
called called her back and i said
i have an idea you know said please
please come down on you let's talk about
i grew up in cleveland as a poor
blue-collar
kid refugee kid and and as i grew up i
met all kinds of
union guys who had been
beaten up and abused by by corporate
people
and companies and and i thought maybe
there's a good movie in this and she
said well i think this is a great idea
why don't you go back and and and try to
talk to these guys that go across the
country
and then we will finance the the
research part of it
so i did and then when it went all
across the country and i discovered
things like the homestead action
you know where where people were really
abused and
beaten nearly to death and after all of
that research i
did a a treatment and i and i handed it
to her and said this is this is really a
wonderful idea
and they brought norman jewison into it
they would done all of these movies and
a lot of it movies and gave it to him
and norman said well come on down to
when i was
27 years old
so i went down and he said you know i
don't know what the hell this thing is
you know it's
not a treatment it's not an outline it's
not exactly a piece of
but but but it's but it's whatever it is
is interesting and um and i'm interested
in it
and but i don't know if this i don't
know what we're gonna do
so norman who was one of the most
generous people that i've ever met
um really met with a wonderful heart mom
and i worked for about six months
um going through this script and going
through this project
and the the it was like i got a master's
seminar
in screenwriting from a man who'd done
14 movies right
more than 14 many more many many mans
so um i wrote this script
and it was like 500 pages long
and i gave it to him
you know this is as big as war and peace
okay well he said we have to trim it
down
and i said there was a scene in this
it was like you know 15 pages long
one scene and he said you've written
this thing that's a 15-page monologue
it's okay he said they're gonna throw
tomatoes at the screen
kid because it's 15 pages
of someone speaking and i was so
green i was a rolling stone reporter and
i said
but listen they're great words aren't
they it's a great thing they're great
dialogue
and he just looked at me with this stony
blinky eyes that bug you
can cut
so he did several drafts and
several horrifying reps and cut this
thing down to
you know to like 116.
um and i fell of course that i was and i
was
murdering myself to do it down to that
page
but but he kept me stuck with it
we got down to about 125
and he had to make a choice between rack
time
um the uh the the you know the
doctoral book and and what we've been
working
and i thought i was that weird to forget
about it you know all this time
two years and rack time it was so
celebrating all that stuff into my
absolute amazement he said okay i'm
gonna do this
okay and then i'm gonna do this thing
and i think this would be delivered
um so he did the movie came
out it absolutely disastered both
critically and commercially
i was in the screenwriter was never set
out to do publicity but
they sent me to pittsburgh
in cleveland so
i was in pittsburgh doing publicity for
the movie and getting up at eight in the
morning to send things in the morning
to do the early shows and then there was
a wonderful guy
named like baptist school and three
theaters
green guy and because among hearing we
identified immediately as a wonderful
guy
he was the guy who took me around to the
to the different shows and all that
and then at the end of it on the third
day
as he's driving me to the airport he
says
joe you're a great kid
but this piece of that you wrote in
three of my theaters
there was nobody there right so
so don't write anything like this again
um the premiere of this was in dubuque
iowa
and on the way there the uh time in
newsweek
did their reviews of times review was
um times was j-u-n-k
instead of this right and newsweek's was
i don't remember it was something
equally derogatory so
we go into buick and norman's there and
they they plan this huge festival like
premiere with
parades and old cars and all this stuff
and i go in there and i say normal jesus
give me a rather abuse he said we're
that meat but keep smiling
and all the way through this smile
and i i did keep smiling
the the vital moment of this was like
three weeks later when the movie is
completing disaster
i spoke to the lady who
who in the beginning had discovered me
and you know
march amassed her kimchi a lot
and i said margin what's gonna happen
now
i mean my god you know i'm no longer
working for holy stone i've read that
i've written the script and it's gone up
in flames both
commercially and critically and what's
going to happen he said honey
um sliced alone is going to become the
biggest star in the world
marmon jewison is going to go on to do
many more movies
and everyone has read your script and
you're going to do many more scripts and
it's my first one
and i said you mean there is no
responsibility
and she said not in hollywood
that's how i started and i did it
personally hurt you
or affect you that it didn't do well and
that they were so
i was i was scared i was certainly
frightened yeah you know because this is
my first one i'd
like a left rolling stone you know i'm
gonna and i love doing the screenplay
and i thought what was gonna happen now
but but so it frightened me but but it
kept going out
now um this was in i think
a 78 and i didn't have another movie
made until 83
because people had read the script and
liked it
they hired me to do other things and and
uh but but the
things they heard me to do were made and
in 83 flash dance was made
um and it was this gigantic movie that
no one expected
right the studio and sold their rights
and all that stuff so
so you know so suddenly they're there we
were and uh
but between 78 and 83
i was really scared so guys if you get
scared
it's okay just keep writing stuff
it's like spitballing and something
might stick against
don't let yourself be defeated and
knocked down it really is a question of
just
keep doing it keep doing
you